in this video we're gonna focus on
enumerated powers versus implied powers
for the federal government enumerated
just means powers that have been made
explicit that are clear that have been
enumerated that have been listed
someplace while implied powers are ones
that maybe aren't as clear maybe they
haven't been explicitly listed but they
are assumed because of certain wording
or just in order to do the enumerated
powers and this is a really important
concept because in any federal system
where you have multiple layers you have
the federal government you have the
state governments and of course you also
have the local governments but this idea
of what powers go to the federal
government versus the state government
is a super important one and it's a
matter of significant debate and it has
changed over time so to just get our
baseline understanding let's sample some
of the enumerated powers to the federal
government inside of the United States
Constitution so this right over here is
article 1 section 8 of the United States
Constitution I'm not going to read it in
its entirety we'll focus on some of
these powers in more detail in other
videos but I will sample it and focus on
some of the clauses that have been
especially cited and have been
especially relevant to the world that we
live in so just a sample so the Congress
shall have the power to lay and collect
taxes duties imposts and excises so
these are very clear enumerated powers
it's listing what the Congress has the
power to do the Congress can borrow
money on the credit of the United States
once again a very clear enumerated power
to regulate commerce with foreign
nations and among the several states and
with the Indian tribes now this clause
right over here and this is now referred
to as the Commerce Clause might not
really stand out to you it might not
stand out to you relative to you know
the right to do it to conduct Foreign
Affairs or something that seems very big
and dramatic like that but it turns out
that the Commerce Clause is viewed as
one of the significant clauses that
gives the federal government significant
rights and its
considered to have really three
enumerated rights embedded in it you
have the regulation of Commerce with
foreign nations the regulation of
Commerce among the several states and
with the Indian tribes and it's the
middle one that is viewed as giving the
federal government a lot of power
because even though it might seem okay
well we're just talking about commerce
between states it's been used to justify
things like federal drug laws that even
if a state argues hey we are just going
to say legalize marijuana within our
states the federal government has cited
that your legalization of marijuana is
going to affect commerce between states
and we'll go into more depth in that in
future videos but the Commerce Clause is
a key enumerated right that's given in
the Constitution that is viewed as
giving the federal government fairly
broad authority but let's continue to
establish a uniform rule of
naturalization who becomes an American
uniform laws on the subject of
bankruptcy keep going I always encourage
you to look at this in context in the
actual Constitution that is always
interesting the reason why I listed all
of these out even though I'm not going
to read them is that it's just
interesting to see how many of these
enumerated rights there are but I'm
gonna focus on the last Clause because
this one is in a lot ways much bigger
than all of the other ones it says to
make all laws which shall be necessary
and proper for carrying into execution
the foregoing powers and all other
powers vested by this constitution in
the government of the United States or
in any department or officer thereof
pause this video think about why this is
a very very very big deal well the
previous 17 clauses were very explicit
they were enumerated powers about what
the federal government has the power to
do but this one here is making a much
broader statement it's saying to make
all laws which shall be necessary and
proper for carrying into execution the
foregoing powers the powers the
enumerated powers the last that we're in
the
last 17 clauses and so this is known as
the Necessary and Proper Clause which
you will hear a lot about Necessary and
Proper and it provides for a lot of
implied powers because it's essentially
saying look there's things that we
haven't listed in the enumerated powers
in the previous 17 clauses but the
federal government has the right to make
all laws which shall be necessary and
proper for carrying into execution the
foregoing powers and so even when I was
talking about say federal drug laws it's
really the combination of the Commerce
Clause and the Necessary and Proper
Clause that allows the federal
government to make some of these broader
arguments that says okay we regulate
commerce and in order to regulate
commerce we need to regulate drugs
because it is necessary and proper for
regulating interstate commerce so we're
going to talk more and more about this
especially when we look at specific
constitutional cases that will cite
these clauses but it's really important
to appreciate what enumerated powers are
what implied powers are which the
Necessary and Proper Clause gives a lot
of and the anti-federalists really did
not like this eighteenth Clause
understanding the ideas of enumerated
implied powers is going to be really
helpful as we study the various disputes
over state versus federal powers
throughout American history and how it
is decided on by say the Supreme Court
when they cite the Constitution and in
particular cite some of the clauses that
we have just looked at